It is known as the Rainbow Nation for
its cultural,
linguistic and religious diversity.
Its Constitution alone acknowledges 11
different languages.
Yes,
this is South Africa or a country
situated in the extreme south of
average.
Gotcha.
It's not a small country.
It's surface area is laundry than
Germany,
France,
Italy,
Belgium,
and the Netherlands combined.
It is by far the most developed economy
of all the countries situated south of
the Sahara desert.
In the year 2010 it was the first
African country to holds a soccer world
championship.
This was the summer of [inaudible] Waka
Waka,
anyone cast around then?
Yeah.
The box
pours in month in South Africa's history
was April,
1994 between the 26th and 29th of that
month,
South Africa celebrated the first free
universal ends,
democratic elections.
They were all seeing the longest because
the election's lasted for four long
days.
During that time,
South Africans left the house as
massively devote.
Having to wait in queues at kilometers
long
ahead
was justified for these elections.
Men to the ends of 300 years of
colonialism and white supremacy.
The elections mark to the end of
apartheid.
Apartheid
was this system based on racial
segregation,
which remains in effect for 50 years.
It mainly consisted of separating the
whites population from the black
population.
This applies in any situation,
living,
studying,
even the spending of leisure time.
Obviously,
as you might imagine,
all of the best areas and services were
built for bands used by the white
population.
A good example of this was the
ambulances.
Even though the black population where
80% of the population they barely had
any ambulances to use.
However,
the ambulances for the white population
were numerous and refused to carry any
black passengers because they couldn't
see according to the law.
Okay.
[inaudible] gave the white population
all the political power and also
established many limitations precisely
in order to consolidate that white
power.
As an example,
mixed race relationships and marriage
work and for business.
Quite simply,
it left the black population in an
inhumane
be
said that there were two different South
Africa's one black and terribly poor and
the other white,
and it's very wealthy and of course
those who rebels itself at a terrible
punishments and repression.
On the 16th of June,
1976 thousands of black students went on
the demonstration to demand social and
educative improvements.
Hundreds of them were massacred.
I got into Denmark.
I have this guy in my bag.
I was running over the,
they dumped that just writing away from
the,
from the police dream,
but all that changed in 1994 thanks for
Nelson Mandela,
also known as Madiba.
He was considered the father of the
country.
Mandela led the political fight against
apartheid and racism.
God's,
he had to pay for it.
In 1961 he was sentenced to life
imprisonment for the trail.
Mandela spent 27 years in jail until
1992 nevertheless,
two years after it was released in 1994
during the country's first free
elections,
he was elected as the president of South
Africa,
the first black president in the
country's history.
Often this happens.
Many were surprised to see Mandela
aiming for reconciliation rather than
revenge and Della Dreamt of a free your
90 days and it's prosperous South
Africa.
He made it clear in his inaugural
speech,
we have time and I thought the implant
hoping the on the Miller of Rp,
we have dry into our covenant that wish
I healed the society in which all South
Africa can I can.
Why wouldn't be able to walk,
talk without tenure?
Fear in their hearts.
I saw off the hype of human dignity.
Grain partners at peace with itself and
the wealth.
Mandela caps is worse.
He works towards the United South
Africa.
It's when the time came,
he left power following the limits of
the constitution.
This all turns him into a legend
country.
What does Rebecca for Bay?
The past is the past.
We look to the future now.
Well,
let's now focus on present day South
Africa.
It is the only country in the world's to
have three capital cities,
Cape Town,
the capital city for legislative power,
Pretoria for executive power and it's
blue fontane feed judicial capitol city,
and on top of all that,
neither is the most populated.
All the one where most businesses
concentrates.
For that we have to move to a fourth
city Johannesburg.
It's even not uncommon for different
textbooks to stay to different cities as
the capital of South Africa.
Now after the fall of apartheid,
South Africa experienced quite an
economic boost since 1994 the economy
considering purchasing power has it
great.
He
has been strongly reduced.
Ends a hundreds of thousands of black
families make it into the middle class
every single year.
I even Lou violence is still high.
It doesn't need to be said that South
Africa is quite a violent country.
It has also been reduced further in
general,
the access to drinkable water,
electricity and healthcare has also
improved quite a lot.
Do you illustrate the situation?
South Africa is the biggest tourist
center and its financial power in the
south of the continent.
It stock market is the most important in
Africa.
I did is also an important place for the
automotive industry.
Companies such as BMW and General Motors
have factories out.
So it all sounds pretty good,
right?
Well things today are not looking that
rosie crises on stagnation,
just licensed numerous achievements.
The economy hasn't changed since 2009
the economy isn't growing.
Unemployment rates,
I'll one of the highest in the world and
in general,
very few people are working the country.
It has a population of about 55 million
people,
50 million of which are without work and
as many of the jobs that the people do
have.
Our informal,
and this is not the only problem.
Investment by companies has also kept a
decreasing in the last nine years.
It's currency.
The rand is also greatly depreciate it
and it's public debt is about to be
declared as junk bonds.
This is a pretty major economic
disaster.
In fact,
in the last years people with money have
begun leaving the country.
So the big question is what happens in
South Africa?
What led to this crisis?
This is Jacob Zuma.
He's been in office since 2009 and his
years in office have been,
well,
they've been a giant mess.
My man is facing at 783 corruption cases
and he has been described at being a
professional ads taking things that are
not his
South Africa's main opposition party is
accusing President Jacob Zuma or of
flagrant abuse of public money is a
multimillion euro.
Upgrades to his home.
Additions to zoomers home include a
swimming pool,
cattle enclosure and an amphitheater.
This is not the only issue.
Mr Zoom is political decisions don't
encourage foreign investment.
Further the president's labor
regulations.
There are an obstacle when it comes to
job creation and the regulations are
getting more and more rigid has last
idea.
It was a huge raise in the minimum wage.
It's something that doesn't make a bunch
of sense in a country where there are so
few working people.
In fact,
many financial analysts have criticized
the measure by saying it's nonsensical
to establish a minimum wage,
which amounts do twice as much as half
of work as I'm making.
Now,
to be honest,
we all do once our salaries to raise,
but I think it's a better idea to create
some wealth first if job creation was
already an issue before,
imagine what's going to happen with
higher salaries and South Africa has
other problems too and important.
One is it's problematic education
system,
an awful education system.
The education system in South Africa is
pretty awful.
Picture this one in every three students
who has attended school for six years
has difficulty when it comes to
something as essential as reading and
only one in every 100 black students
gets an engineering diploma.
So we can probably,
no one understands why.
National companies complain about the
difficulty of finding skilled labor and
this has got nothing to do with money.
South Africa is one of the countries
with the highest investments in
education in the world.
The question is,
what is happening?
Well,
according to some people,
the ones who are to blame are the
Democratic Teacher's Union.
They control the state education system
and it has become something of a Mafia.
The union is an ally of President Zuma
Zuma.
Besides putting it into education
supervision,
there's also pulls many strings to get
more teachers into the system.
This is because the education level of
teachers themselves to become a very
low.
Now,
a few years ago,
maths teachers in the country were given
a task.
These teachers were teaching math to 11
and 12 year olds.
What was the result?
Well,
eight hours of these teachers got lower
results and we're expected of their
students and to be honest in maths is
not exactly one of president zoom as
strong suits.
This is President Zuma attempting to say
769,817
769 800 ten seven hundred one property,
810 20
no
via sneak the results for white
students.
So you go to private schools are far
better.
This shows that maybe some of the
apartheid heritage is still very much in
a fact
race.
So conflict if these problems weren't
bad enough.
Racial conflict in South Africa has also
been growing in the last few years.
The economic freedom fighters is a
radical political party that was founded
in 2015 this party is an lv third
largest force in the country.
Some of its members are suggesting to
almost inverted apartheid and plants and
the white population.
It is still a minority party,
but is an element of subversion.
It is working quite well.
So anyway,
it now it looks as if Mandela's dream,
it's now in danger.
So this is what we think here of Israel
politic.
But what do you think,
do you think the South Africa will
continue to pursue Nelson Mandela's
dream?
Do you think it will become the most
prosperous nation in Africa?
Once again,
what'd you think?
Hatred,
distrust,
and bad politics.
We'll try and do.
Let us know in the comments section
below this video.
We'd love to know what you think.
Also,
if you did enjoy this video,
please do click that thumbs up button
below and don't forget to subscribe if
you haven't already for brand new videos
every Monday and Thursday,
there's a button below the video as well
as on the screen now,
so be sure to click on that and as
always,
I'll see you in the next [inaudible]
too.
Proud.